vandaag
vergelijken we de verkiezingsprogramma's van de bbb
met dat van de sp
en 1 heel belangrijk onderwerp voor heel veel mensen
is op dit moment inkomen
en als we kijken naar het verkiezingsprogramma van bbp
dan zien we dat ze het minimumloon niet willen verhogen
we zien ook dat ze de recordwinsten
niet willen aanpakken
in het verkiezingsprogramma van de sp
daarentegen gaat het minimumloon direct naar 16 euro
en ook de uitkeringen stijgen mee
door recordwinsten
zorgen we dat die worden aangepakt
zodat we dat geld kunnen investeren
in de samenleving en wat voor ons allemaal
van belang is
en 1 ander belangrijk
onderwerp wat voor heel veel mensen speelt
is natuurlijk de wooncrisis
1 goed en betaalbaar huis is
bijna niet meer te vinden voor heel veel mensen
en als we kijken naar het verkiezingsprogramma
van de bbb dan zien we
dat ze van wonen nog steeds 1 markt willen maken
dat ze juist investeerders
weer meer vrijheid willen geven
en het voorstel om de huren te bevriezen heeft het bbp
niet gesteund
in het programma van de sp
zorgen we dat wonen weer trotse volkshuisvesting wordt
de huren
gaan omlaag en we zorgen ervoor dat er geïnvesteerd
wordt in de bouw van betaalbare nieuwe woningen
en dat bestaande
woningen worden verbeterd en verduurzaamd
en 1/3
onderwerp wat natuurlijk nu heel erg speelt is de zorg
en wat ik mooi vond in het programma van de bbb
is dat ze de optie noemen om het eigen risico
af te schaffen
maar helemaal zeker is het nog niet
en ook 1 andere plannen op de zorg zijn
helaas nog erg vaag
het sp programma is veel duidelijker op de zorg
het eigen risico wordt afgeschaft
we investeren in de zorg
in ouderenzorg
in zorg dichtbij
maar juist ook in de ziekenhuiszorg
nu dreigen veel afdelingen of zelfs complete
ziekenhuizen gesloten te worden
dat stopt met dit
stem 22 November sociaal stem sp